كنا وقين على حالنا اشونا قبل خمس ايام
وطلعوا بعدين رجعوا تاني كنا بالبدر احنا
متخبيين خشنا فجروا الضم والاسانسير وكل
المدخل العماره فجروه خشنا رفعنا ايدينا
وقنا لهم نا
خلص نعمل
يخصص
عمي وبعد شويه شلح جوزي واولادي وجو بنت
حماتي وعمي شلوهم البكاسر
واخذوهم واحنا جابوا متفجرات وحطوهم في
قلب العماره ب ي فجروها فينا كنا نقول لهم
خلاص نطلع ع لو بيقوللي 10 دقاق واطلعوا
10 دقاق وطلعنا بره فينا نمشي نمشي بسنا
نمشي مش عارفين ورانا نطلع ورانا الطريق
الطريق شتا وميه وحط ومج والبحر ايش احكي
لك الطريق ايش احكيلك الطريق اي الطريق مش
بدك الطريق اي الطريق مش
قدرين ا خخ
الدنيا رعب يا اختي رعب والله جعين اخذوهم
جحين حسبي الله
عليه ياما يا حبيبتي ياما يابا يا رب
احميهم يا رب يا رب احميهم وهمام المتص
يرش رير جرج
[موسيقى]
همام ابوك بعد مسكو اللي في العماره
اليهود عند الدبابه اخذوه بحسو واخذوه مش
عارفه ليش قنا لهم مريض زعلت عليه
امس صغيره هذ الله يخليكم
لاخوها يا
والله